president trump will finish his term
without his attorney general william
barr
handed in his letter of resignation
yesterday he praised the president that
he had assisted defended and
occasionally rebuffed over the past two
years
ben tracy is at the white house ben why
is barr leaving
now with just about a month left until
president trump leaves office the timing
of this
is certainly strange but it's no secret
that the president has been unhappy with
the attorney general
mainly because barr has not backed up
the president's claims
of election fraud mr attorney general
sources tell cbs news attorney general
bill barr was not
forced out of his job his resignation
letter is a full page tribute to
president trump
barr writes the president's
unprecedented achievements in the face
of a partisan onslaught
bill barr should have stepped up but
lately president trump has been upset
that barr said the department of justice
found no evidence of widespread fraud in
the 2020 election
a direct contradiction of the
president's false claims
barr also followed justice department
procedure when he did not reveal a
federal investigation into hunter biden
during the campaign
but it clearly angered the president
bill barr
frankly did the wrong thing bill barr i
believe
not believe i know had an obligation to
set the record straight
barr's resignation came after the two
met at the white house on monday
in a tweet president trump said our
relationship has been a very good one
and that bar has done an outstanding job
there was no evidence
of the trump campaign collusion with the
russian
government's hacking barr has been a
loyal defender of the president
famously providing his own summary of
the mueller report in 2019
which created space for the president to
claim he had been exonerated
which he was not no collusion no
obstruction but barr has also admitted
the president's interference to the
department of justice
made his job impossible in an interview
with cbs's jan crawford
barr did not seem concerned about his
reputation i'm at the end of my career
i've you know it's a reputation that
you've
worked your whole life on though yeah
but everyone dies and i'm not
you know you know i don't believe in the
homeric idea that you know
immortality comes by you know having
odes sung about you
over the centuries now barr's last day
as attorney general will be december
23rd and with just 36 days left in the
trump administration there won't be time
to confirm
a new attorney general so the deputy
attorney general jeff rosen
he will become the acting attorney
general gail
all right ben got it hopefully that bill
bar will sit down with jan crawford
again i know she'd love to have another
conversation really interesting
conversation
catherine herridge a couple people would
like to talk to bill barr
today thank you very much ben